IAN ROWE: Hello.
It is an honor for
me to be speaking
to you as part of this
very important symposium--
Race in America-- History
and Controversies.
My focus will be
on a key lever that
has been part of a
critical foundation
for empowering the
Black community to move
from persecution to prosperity.
That lever is education and
the power of school choice.
Throughout the
struggle for equality
of access and opportunity,
the ability for a Black parent
to choose a high-quality
school for their child
has been the great equalizer
for the Black community.
But before I share a little
bit about the arduous journey
of the African-American
experience of education
in the United States,
I'd like to tell you
a little bit about
my personal story.
In the late 1960s, my
parents, brother, and I
emigrated from
Jamaica West Indies,
ultimately moving to Laurelton
Queens in New York, at the time
a predominantly white
middle-class community.
Laurelton was transitioning
from a Jewish enclave
to what is now a
neighborhood mostly inhabited
by African-American and
Caribbean residents.
By 1977, I was attending IS231,
a junior high school that
had been historically
mostly white but,
like the surrounding
area, was rapidly
becoming racially integrated.
Racial tensions were
growing with increasingly
bitter and daily disputes.
Driving?
The school leadership
to seek out solutions.
The local school board,
citing overcrowding
as their rationale,
voted to open
an annex, a separate academic
building two miles away
in Rosedale, a small Irish
and Italian-American community
nestled on the border of
Nassau County, Long Island.
That decision led almost
every white family
in my junior high school
to transfer their children
to the annex in
September of 1977,
leaving IS231 a segregated,
virtually all-Black school.
My Jamaican immigrant
parents, determined
that their two sons
would get a real shot
at the American dream, were
ready to transfer me as well.
Wherever go the White kids, so
goes the quality of education
was their theory.
I was 12 years old, and
my parents knew best.
But something was
not right here.
I didn't want to
leave my school,
and I did not like the reasons
my parents were giving me
for doing so.
It is a strange and
mildly terrifying thing
to consider standing up
to the people you love.
And up until that
point in my life,
I had never
questioned my parents
about anything that mattered.
Why would I question the two
people who had repeatedly
demonstrated that they had only
my best interests at heart?
But something inside me said no.
I found a voice that
I never knew existed.
On the Sunday
evening before they
had to file the
transfer documents,
I stood in our living room,
pleading with my dad ensconced
in his brown recliner
and locking eyes
with my mom witnessing her
youngest son muster courage
that she had not ever seen.
I begged my parents
to reconsider,
to let me stay in IS231.
I remember thinking
to myself and then
bravely saying out loud,
why should the other school
be better?
Why should the education
suddenly be worse in my school
just because most of the
kids who are going to be left
are Black?
I liked my teachers and I didn't
see why my education would
have to suffer just
because I wasn't
going to go to the school
with all the white kids.
I told my parents if they
let me stay in IS231,
I would work even harder.
They would not regret
their decision.
I promised.
They could believe in me
because I believed in myself.
And regardless of what
they were to decide,
something had awakened
in me to give me
the confidence to respectfully
challenge my parents.
I was now an active player
in my own education,
and to a larger
degree, my own destiny.
I made a choice.
I was becoming an
agent of my own uplift.
And then something
extraordinary happened.
My parents relented.
They let me stay at IS231.
And with the support of
my parents and teachers,
I received a public
education that
made me believe
anything was possible.
I ultimately entered Brooklyn
Technical High School,
went on to graduate with
a Bachelor of Science
in Computer Science Engineering
at Cornell University,
and later earned my MBA from
Harvard Business School.
My parents and that
choice of education
made all the difference.
And now, come full-circle,
for the last decade,
I was the CEO of a nonprofit
network of public charter
schools in the heart of the
South Bronx in New York City,
hoping to inspire thousands
of low-income, primarily
Black and Hispanic students
to understand the pathways
through which they could become
agents of their own uplift.
In a sense, the parents of
the Black and brown children
I now educated have
the same aspirations
that my parents had for me,
for many Black children,
and for children of all races.
That education is the ticket
to reach the American dream.
But it has not always been so.
Due to the legacy of
slavery, in the mid-1800s,
Black people had
very little access
to high-quality education.
In slave states,
anti-literacy laws
banned Black people
from accessing education
on the premise that a tipping
point of literate slaves
might lead to insurrection
and rebellion.
For example, South
Carolina had a law
that would jail a
person for six months
and impose crippling fines if
you even attempted to teach
a slave to read and write.
Things did not get much better
during the Jim Crow era, which
legally segregated schools.
During that time, like
much of everyday life,
public schools were
segregated by race.
They were separate and
profoundly unequal.
There were huge disparities
in funding between Black
and white schools, facilities,
access to equipment,
and most importantly, the
quality of the education
itself.
In 1896, the Supreme
Court in the case
of Plessy versus Ferguson
ruled that separate but equal
was fair and it
was not a violation
of the 14th Amendment, requiring
equal protection to all.
This ruling meant that the
federal government would not
challenge segregation, even
despite the deeply inferior
conditions that Black
students were subject to,
especially in education.
Separate but equal and Jim
Crow remained unchallenged
until Brown versus Board
of Education in 1954
and the Civil
Rights Act of 1964.
It is against this backdrop,
when racial segregation was
at its worst, that an unlikely
partnership transformed
education for two
generations of Black students
in the rural South.
Educator, activist,
public intellectual,
and founder of the
Tuskegee Institute.
Booker T. Washington.
Had?
Himself experience
firsthand the destitution
and profound racial
disparities in the rural South.
Despite these
obstacles, Washington's
perseverance and disciplined
upbringing eventually
led to an education
at what is now
known as Hampton University.
And as an adult, Washington
dreamed of a school building
project for Black communities
throughout the South
that could help begin to lift
Black people out of poverty.
Washington presented
his ambitious idea
to build a network of schools
to Julius Rosenwald, who
at the time was a CEO
of the nation's largest
retailer, Sears.
Rosenwald was a supporter
of the Tuskegee Institute,
so he had a deep respectful
relationship with Washington.
Washington collaborated
with Julius Rosenwald,
and together they
crafted a plan to make
Washington's dream a reality.
In a region of the United
States in which Jim Crow
racial segregation
was law, lynching
was a common and
a brutal reality,
and rural poverty was widespread
on both sides of the color
line, these Rosenwald
facilities were typically
constructed, maintained,
and partially
funded by the populations
that they served,
becoming centers of
local social life
and sources of community pride.
Over the years to
construct the buildings,
Rosenwald contributed
$4.4 million,
or what today would
be nearly $80 million.
And importantly,
$4.7 million came
from local Black communities in
the form of cash, labor, land,
and materials.
Washington and Rosenwald had
launched a challenge grant
program that ultimately led to
the unprecedented construction
of more than 5,000 school
buildings, 4,977 schools, 217
teachers' homes, and 163
shop buildings in 15 states
from Maryland to Texas, all
dedicated to the education
of Black students.
While the required donation from
African-American communities
amounted to double taxation,
their leaders nonetheless
called on residents to organize
fundraising drives to cover
their share of each new school.
"Get busy, Laurel, or
hang your heads in shame,"
admonished the Prince George's
Colored Public School Trustees
in a 1924 report describing
the existing pitiful
buildings in the town of Laurel.
These efforts to build or
renovate new school buildings
were impressive.
In one instance, struggling
sharecroppers set aside
an area planted with
cotton as the quote,
"Rosenwald patch," end quote,
and donated the profits
from its sale to the school.
Children saved pennies
in snuff boxes.
And at one fundraising
rally, an old man
who had been a slave offered
his life savings of $38 to,
quote, "see the children of my
grandchildren have a chance,"
end quote.
In the years between World
War I and World War II,
the Rosenwald Schools
helped close the gap
between White and Black
academic achievement.
Researchers at the
Chicago Federal Reserve
concluded that in the regions
where the Rosenwald Rural
Schools Initiative built
most of its 5,000 schools,
the education gap between
Southern-born Black
and white males narrowed
sharply in areas
such as school attendance,
literacy, and cognitive test
scores.
Using census data and
World War II records,
the researchers found
that Rosenwald's program
explained a stunning
40% narrowing
of the racial education gap.
While the Rosenwald
schools were thriving,
a major case was being litigated
over segregation in 1954.
The Supreme Court
made a landmark ruling
that school segregation was
unconstitutional in Brown
versus Board of Education.
The fundamental premise
was that, quote,
"Separate is inherently
unequal," end quote.
So exclusively Black or white
schools were now outlawed.
So a decision
intended to improve
outcomes for Black
children assumed
separate had to mean inferior.
The terrible irony is
that decision actually
had the perverse
impact of making
the very existence of
the Rosenwald Schools
a violation of the law.
So even with its extraordinary
record of success,
the Rosenwald schools
were quickly abandoned.
Despite student protests over
their closing and demolition,
most of the schools
were gone by the 1970s.
The Rosenwald Schools
remain today one
of the greatest examples
of strong partnership
across racial lines, Black
excellence, and ironically,
the victim of
unintended consequences.
Fast forward to today.
While progress has been
made with more than 3
million Black students
enrolled in college today,
there are still deep
academic racial disparities
in pockets of American society.
For example, of the
nearly 2,000 public school
students beginning high
school in the South Bronx,
where I led a network of
charter schools in 2015, only 2%
of kids in this
district graduated ready
for college four years later.
A shocking 98% of
students either
dropped out of high
school before completing
their senior year or they
did manage to graduate,
but would still be
required to take
remedial classes in
community college
due to low math and reading
scores on state exams.
By contrast, charter public
schools in the South Bronx
continue to outperform
their district peers
in both math and reading in
third through eighth grade
by a substantial margin.
It comes as no
surprise that parents
in these predominantly Black
and Hispanic communities
encompassing two of the
poorest congressional districts
in the country are desperate
for higher-quality education
options.
The New York City
Charter Center reports
that in the Bronx alone,
more than 25,000 families
applied for just over 9,000
available seats in Bronx
charter schools.
This overwhelming
demand demonstrates
that parents want the
best for their children
and should be given
the power of choice.
Many of these parents may have
faced racial discrimination
and other challenges
in their own lives,
and fear that their
children might as well.
But they know that
a great education
can make a huge difference.
They do not believe
that their children are
doomed to be shackled by
the horrors of America's
legacy of slavery.
They know that if teachers had
the highest of expectations
and were empowered
with a curriculum that
could help their
children develop
character-based strengths
like integrity, resiliency,
and agency, the
belief that you can
be the master of
your own destiny,
then those children could
lead life on their own terms,
even in the face of
structural barriers.
That is why I must
mention the 1619
Project, a major initiative
and series of essays
from the New York
Times Magazine.
For a year, the authors
have repeated the claim
that the country's, quote,
"true founding," end quote,
was 1619 and not 1776, when
the Declaration of Independence
was signed.
1619 claims that America was
founded as a slavocracy, not
a democracy, that
anti-Black racism
runs in the very
DNA of the country.
The 1619 Project also claims
that America's founding ideals
were false when
they were written,
and that the nation
was founded on a lie.
Despite the fact that the 1619
Project has been discredited
by dozens of the most
well-respected historians
in the country,
particularly the claim
that the Civil War was
fought to defend slavery,
the New York Times
was not satisfied
with just the special
edition of the magazine.
They partnered with
the Pulitzer Center
to create a curriculum
that has now been adopted
in thousands of classrooms.
School districts in Chicago,
Illinois, Washington, DC,
and Buffalo, New York began
implementing the project
in their K-12 course materials.
These are some of the lowest
academically performing
schools in the country.
As an educator who has spent
the last 10 years working
with families who believe
and want their child
to have the American
dream, the last thing
their children need to
hear is false information
about our country.
Yes, America has
a terrible history
of slavery and oppression, but
America is not defined solely
by its legacy of slavery.
We want all children to know
of the legacy of excellence
alongside the legacy of
slavery, and the lessons
that are relevant to
All-American children.
There are innumerable examples
of individuals and groups
that have gone from
persecution to prosperity
by embracing America's
founding ideals of family,
free enterprise, faith, hard
work, and entrepreneurship.
That is why I'm so proud to
say that in the same spirit
that Booker T. Washington
demonstrated to envision how
education could be a
pathway to prosperity,
how he had an idea to
build a network of schools
throughout the South, even in
the face of bitter and often
lethal racial
discrimination, well,
today, a group of talented
Black scholars and activists
have come together
to do the same.
This initiative, called 1776
Unites, is led by Bob Woodson.
For 40 years, Bob
Woodson developed a list
of 10 principles that
he has used in order
to help local
communities transform
struggling neighborhoods and to
empower the people within them.
These 10 principles include
competence, integrity,
transparency, resilience,
witness, innovation,
inspiration, agency,
access, and grace.
These 10 principles now
undergird a new 1776 Unites
curriculum which
we'll ultimately
develop into a K
program for all schools
wherever character formation
is happening for children.
Every lesson will connect
back to one or more
of the Woodson principles.
The 1776 Unites curriculum
offers authentic, inspiring
stories from America's
past and present
that show what is best
in our national character
and what our freedom makes
possible, even in the most
difficult circumstances.
1776 Unites includes two
major components, a look back
and a look forward.
The look back maintains
a special focus
on stories and lesson plans
that celebrate Black excellence,
reject victimhood culture, and
showcase African-Americans past
and present who have
prospered by embracing
America's founding ideals
of free enterprise, family,
hard work,
entrepreneurship, and faith.
Two examples include Biddy
Mason, an amazing woman who
was born a slave but
died a millionaire
and a philanthropist, and Elijah
McCoy, a son of escaped slaves
who became a talented engineer
and inventor whose products
were so superior that inferior
knockoffs were created
to the point that when engineers
went to buy McCoy's products
and were offered the
copies, they said, no, I
want the real McCoy.
Many Americans may
know that phrase
but do not know it is
connected to a Black engineer,
the son of slaves.
These are just two of
the multitude of stories
that will be in the look back
section of the 1776 Unites
curriculum.
The look forward
component includes
units that teach
life lessons that
help the next generation
understand the series of life
decisions that give
them the greatest
likelihood of economic
success as they make choices
as they make their passage
into young adulthood.
Despite real racial
barriers that are out there,
there are millions of
examples of Black excellence.
We constantly study poverty.
What can we learn from
Black Americans who've
been successful in
pursuing the American dream
and their decisions around
education, work, marriage,
and children?
For example, teaching
the data associated
with what's called the success
sequence, the data that
shows if you finish
a high school degree,
secure a full-time job of any
kind, so you learn the dignity
and discipline of work, and
if you have children, marriage
first, 98% of the people
who follow those steps avoid
poverty, and the
vast majority end up
in the middle class or beyond.
That's the kind of information
that young people of all races
need to know to increase
their likelihood of being
economically successful.
In the case of my
own parents, that
is how they achieved
the American dream
and made it possible
for me to do the same.
I often wonder what would have
happened if my parents had not
acquiesced, and
instead insisted that I
attend the annex with
almost all White students.
Would I have exhibited the
same level of ownership
over my learning as I did when
I convinced them to grant me
my wish to stay?
Yet in allowing me
to forge a path that
went against their
better judgment,
my parents taught me
a valuable lesson.
My effort could and would
have to influence my outcomes.
At the time, I felt an enormous
added responsibility to make
my parents' decision worth
the trust that they had placed
in me.
I am convinced the feeling that
I had on that long ago Sunday
evening, the faith I
was expressing in myself
and appealing to my parents
to reluctantly accept
was what I now understand to
be my sense of personal agency.
That self-belief
was the precursor
to the ensuing efforts and
actions necessary for me
to fulfill the commitment
that I had made to my parents,
and most importantly to myself.
But what was also
important was the fact
that my parents had the
ability to choose and to chart
a path through education
to make life better for me,
and, by extension,
the next generation.
It is through this type of
innovation and commitment,
whether it be Booker T.
Washington, or Bob Woodson,
or my parents, that young
Americans of all races
can understand that
even while race
has been an issue
in our country,
it is actually the
power of education,
the power of America's
founding ideals
and our founding
documents signed
in 1776 that have
within them tools
for self-renewal
and self-betterment.
In chapter 13 of de
Tocqueville's America,
he said, quote, "The
greatness of America
lies not in being
more enlightened
than any other
nation, but rather
in her ability to repair
her faults," end quote.
I have always found that
statement compelling,
because it resonates
with the notion
that America is always
in pursuit of becoming
a more perfect union.
While the founders laid
out, inspiring ideals,
we are in a constant effort
to fully live up to them.
That is the critical story
about race and education,
because how we make
steady progress is
through reminding and embracing
those founding ideals,
helping our next
generation to do that,
and not rejecting them.
Thank you.